all right how does it feel to be back
together
[Applause]
it's so special for all of us to connect
again and we take every opportunity we
can to get together really yeah who's
the glue that holds everybody together
sabrina the teenage witch first cast a
spell over audiences in 1996. allow me
all these years later they have a new
generation of fans thanks to streaming
i'll smell you later just two days ago
got a message asking if i could record a
little video saying hi for a
six-year-old it blows my mind that this
many years later six-year-olds are
watching it like it's brand new and it's
their favorite show that really is
grown-ups i mean i walk my dog and
people are like there's a marathon today
i'm sabrina and i'm like
you're 70 years old
we never watched it we were saying we
were too busy we literally worked for
however many years nobody ever saw it
well people are shocked when we say we
never saw it so i've never watched it
billy great guest stars oh we had the
most amazing guest stars actually i
think jean's a very lovely name we loved
like davey jones and uh barbara eaton
barbara oh yeah blondies
and we got you know current pop stars
too obviously like in sync battery boys
uh
uh britney spears everybody wanted to be
on the show because
their either their kids watched it or
they watched it
e.t was on set many times during the
show's seven seasons and we brought
receipts i have a clip it's melissa
an interview from back in the day
everyone working as a team the cast the
writers are really clever why are you 45
in this clip when you're 16 years old i
look like i'm wearing an audrey hepburn
costume or something yeah i think it
just really pulls together what advice
would you give that melissa back in i
don't think you're
you've got body images like problems
like just enjoy yourself we were very
hard on ourselves yeah we didn't take it
to extremes but i i do see that younger
self of my and want to like tell her
like it's okay it's okay you have a
slice of pizza i'm just gonna have a
bite where would your characters be
today i think i'd be a what a very
successful mechanic with his own garage
hi harvey
libby would be steamrolling over every
committee and pta everybody talks all
the time about you know what a what a a
reboot would look like and is it that
you know if we're married do we have
kids that then find out that they have
powers and then the grained ants come
along and of course we'd want to do it
[Music]
you